america
1941
a free america
a secure america
an industrial america
building guns airplanes ships and tanks
filling orders for shells tools metals
machines
backbone of the defense program
is the american worker
men like these
women like these
in factories like these the office of
production management sends this message
to the workers of the united states
to all parts of the country the call
goes out
to every unemployed man and woman who is
available for work or training in
occupations required by defense
industries the message is
register today at your local state
employment office
to workers with skills needed in
aircraft ship building and machine shops
and machine tool manufacturing the
message is
register at once if you are not using
this skill
in your present job
this registration is voluntary
workers
all who are available for jobs in
defence industries
register at your state employment office
register now
find your place in the building of
america's defense
help to protect
free america